all right now we have part two of uh our
mi
the
segment where we go to reddit
and we read their moral quandaries to
discover who is the a-hole we'll start
with this so my boyfriend and i both
work the day shift so we're both home
after 6 p.m we have our days off set up
okay first of all she started a sentence
with the word so so she's already an
a-hole
it's another thing i hate
i'm in a really bad mood right now i've
realized
so i'm just everyone's an a-hole this
time we have our days off set up that uh
he is off saturdays and sundays and i'm
off sundays and mondays we each get one
day off to ourselves to just be alone
and do our thing and then one day off
together to do whatever we want as well
my boyfriend and i have fairly different
hobbies he's really into fitness and
working out and always being active i'm
a pretty strong gamer and i don't care
about any of this who cares what is your
complaint lady so he stayed up stupid
late last night and called into work
this morning nine times out of ten i
wouldn't care but it's monday it's my
only day to myself and he's constantly
bugging me to go to work out with him or
go on a hike or generally to just be
active because he's bored oh god forbid
he's trying to help you help you be a
fit and healthy person he doesn't want
you to to die of heart disease god
forbid yeah my boyfriend is so annoying
he wants me to do things like stand up
my boyfriend wants me to
walk outside encounter the sun every
every once in a while again nine times
out of ten wouldn't matter and i'd spend
a few days doing whatever he wanted i
need this day to just be quiet and dark
and me time i'm 100 on the opposite end
of a social person i just want my one
day to be alone to recuperate for the
week i look forward to this one day the
entire week i'm definitely annoyed and
definitely showing it even though i'm
trying not to i've tried explaining this
i've tried being nice and just telling
him that i need some me time and he's
just not listening i pretty much snapped
and told him to just leave me the f
alone for a bit and now he's sulking in
the living room
am i the a-hole okay and then there's
even more information that we don't need
so you got into a fight with your
boyfriend and he's sucked off and you
immediately went on your phone to reddit
now reddit says that this woman is not
the a-hole and reddit is wrong this time
and not for the first time you're
definitely the a-hole for a few reasons
first of all why are you playing house
why are you playing marriage you know by
living together if you don't even want
to be around each other so you can't
stand to be around the guy for more than
one day of the week but you're living
with him this is not working out okay
you guys need to break up just break up
take my advice go live on your own or
you don't want to live on your own
because you don't have to pay for it
right that's that's probably it so you
want the boyfriend there to help you pay
for the rent or maybe pay pay all the
rent i don't know but you don't actually
be around him what you're looking for is
welfare okay go live on your own and get
on welfare don't give me this oh i need
i need space i need me time i need i
need to relax i need to you're just
dating someone you have no kids
you know you work a nine to five job you
have off on the weekends and you're
complaining about how you need space and
time and i really need my break
for what
like you live some kind of stressful
life this is the only workout that many
people get is just complaining about how
i'm so stressed in my life i'm so
stressed i cannot even
conceive of having an existence as easy
as you and you're still whining is there
anyone who's not an a-hole
i think i'm just the a-hole this time
well let me ask you something what if
there was someone out there who kept the
log of every single thing you did every
minute of the day i think that'd be
pretty creepy well what if i told you
that's exactly what happens every time
you go online your internet provider
like at t or comcast is allowed to store
logs of every website you've ever
visited and they can legally sell this
data to anyone they want that's why i
always use expressvpn expressvpn
reroutes your internet connection
through their secure server so your
internet provider can't see or log what
you're doing online now many of you if
you're more perceptive you might be
wondering well if i'm routing all my
data through a vpn then doesn't the vpn
get to log and see all my data and
you're right to think that way many vpns
claim to have a no logs policy but have
been caught logging customer activity
anyway expressvpn is the only vpn i
trust because they use trusted server
technology stop letting people keep logs
of what you do online visit
expressvpn.com
walsh yt right now and find out how you
can get three months free
let's see my mom has a huge pot belly
pig as a pet okay now here's a story i
want to read
this is an actual important story she
rescued him from a farm he's seven years
old i believe
back when i was planning my wedding my
mom kept on trying to add things to my
wedding specifically for the pig
for example she wanted him to have his
own buffet i turned all her ideas down
and told her the pig will not be
attending my wedding it's got to be a
fake story but i like it anyway even
after i told her i didn't want him at my
wedding she continued to try to get me
to plan my wedding around him she told
me that she needs him to be there
because it's her support animal he isn't
a registered support animal even though
he does bring her a big deal of comfort
in my husband's culture pigs are seen as
dirty animals and it would absolutely be
unfitting for me to have a pig at our
wedding especially because it would be
disrespectful to his family as opposed
to all the other cultures well that
would be totally normal right
well my mom decides to bring her pet pig
to my wedding anyway even after i told
her not to and she showed up late i
could tell my husband was highly upset
with it but stop me when i went to
confront her because he didn't want his
new mother-in-law to hate him was this
thing written by a pig because i can't
even hardly read it my sister-in-law
ended up getting scared because the pig
rubbed up against her which caused the
pig to get scared and run off and bump
into some expensive glass decorations
which ended up falling a break in the
pieces this is not real this didn't
happen come on i think i saw this
episode of king of queens i was beyond
angry at my mom this would have never
happened if she didn't bring her pig to
my wedding so i yelled to her to leave
this didn't happen at all but i hope it
did because you know what if it did if
it did happen then you are the a-hole
not your mom this would be amazing like
weddings are so boring and i understand
this is a contradiction for me i'm a big
proponent of the holy sacrament of
matrimony i think people should get
married i think it's wonderful
but it's really boring too and uh it is
just excruciatingly boring weddings are
by trying to keep the pig out this is
like a source of entertainment and this
is a wedding that people will remember
that's the other thing you want your
wedding to be memorable don't you and
most weddings are not memorable they're
forgotten
for you you might talk about them later
our wedding was a magical day no one
else thought it was magical everyone
else was bored out of their minds for
most of it this is memorable this is
incredible i am fully on board with uh
barn animals being included in wedding
parties just for the entertainment
factor okay we'll read one more i have a
13 month old son who has my last name
because his dad wasn't interested in
fatherhood originally he had a change of
heart and tracked us down two months ago
to be frank i'm still angry he tried to
make me abort our son and then washed
his hands of me when i wouldn't obey him
so besides the financial help i'm not
grateful or happy about a change of
heart he asked me if i would change our
son's last name to his it made me angry
because i'm the one who wanted him i
carried him and raised him alone until
two months ago so i don't think he
deserves for our son to have his last
name however i know it would benefit our
son to have a bigger connection to his
father's family in the long run so i
told him i would change his last name to
his for x amount of money he was visibly
angry and made a comment about how i
wasn't as innocent as he thought and he
told me i was very good at hiding my
true colors while he did agree to give
me the money he's being cold towards me
now and i keep thinking about what he
said which is making me feel like a real
a-hole now somehow again reddit has said
that this woman is not the a-hole when
she clearly is now she might not be the
a-hole because there are two a-holes the
father's an a-hole like showing back up
didn't want any one you wanted one of
the child aborted didn't want to be part
of the child's life and then you show up
now you want to be a part of the child's
life and that's good that's a good part
you had a change of heart but then like
two months later you're saying give the
child my name you have to earn that by
being present in the family now if this
was a normal situation healthy situation
where you're the father and you're there
from the get-go then uh then yes the
child should have your last name to
begin with but not in this case however
this woman you are still 100
000 the a-hole because you tried to sell
your son's naming rights what is he a
stadium why not go auction him off to a
bank let's call him a pnc or wells fargo
sell his forehead to uh best buy they
can slap a logo on it and you think
you're the good guy well i know it'd be
really important for my son to be
connected to his father's family
no you're the a-hole he's the a-hole i'm
the a-hole we're all the a-hills
on this episode of am i the a-hole
he's
she's
cause we're on